thank you
the prophet Muhammad
told us whoever builds a mosque for
Allah Allah will build for him a Sim at
the house in Jannah and we know the
great reward that will not only be
gained but rather will fill your grave
after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masjid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masjid yes that will be something that
you'll have on your scale
how are you guys doing Andrew hoberman
an individual
who is a specialist in dopamine from
what I understand uh has his own
laboratory and uh speaks at length on
podcasts online relating to dopamine in
particular but also testosterone
um hormones and uh and or and
neurotransmitters and how that has an
impact on the psycho uh physiological
state of the human being
has said something quite interesting
about pornography so I wanted to just
see a part of what he said and then come
back and respond in kind there's an
additional issue with pornography which
is not often discussed which is that
remember guys in particular
the brain is a learning prediction
machine and if
I'm not trying to say that all
pornography is bad but there are good
data to support the idea that if your
brain learns to be aroused by watching
other people have sex
it is not necessarily going to carry
over to the ability to get aroused when
you're one-on-one with somebody else
right the especially young kids who are
consuming a lot of pornography the brain
is learning sexual arousal to
other people having so you're going to
program yourself into being a voyeur or
yeah or just create challenges in in
sexual interactions with you know with
with peer with a with a real partner
Mary Harrington has the three laws of
pornodynamics and the second law of
porno Dynamics is the law of FAP entropy
and it says that whatever you start out
wanking to will get progressively more
intense over time and I think that this
is sort of speaking to that ever ever
sort of escalating amount of
um the wildness that you need to watch
in order to get an Ever decreasing
stimulus that comes back yeah and you
know here I'm I'm approaching this only
through the lens of biology right I'm
not a you know I'm not a psychologist
and I'm certainly not
um political in it in any way at least
not I have ideas about politics but I
just don't discuss them publicly but the
but the idea here is that you know I'm
not saying pornography as a stimulus is
bad or good what I'm saying is it
in its availability and it's extreme
forms it's a very potent stimulus and
very potent stimuli of any kind
extremely palatable food extreme
pornography extreme experiences like
bungee cord jumping those set a
threshold for dopamine release and Anna
will tell you that and I'm sure she did
that the higher the dopamine Peak the
bigger the drop afterwards and it's not
that you drop to Baseline you drop below
Baseline I think it's interesting what
he said here because he's coming at it
from a purely you know scientific
perspective and obviously from our
perspective we do believe that
pornography is a sin we believe that
looking at the opposite gender in a
lustful way looking at nakedness and so
on is a sin and so on and many people
will know that this is obviously part of
the traditionalist religious Mantra it's
not just us as Muslims of course Jews
and Christians will feel the same way
about these issues and many other people
from different spiritual backgrounds
but what I found quite interesting is he
was relating it to our state of being
from a dopamine perspective now there's
something I want to say to preface the
discussion about Andrew hoberman I do
believe that he's a physicalist and
Hamza zoltzes who's the CEO of the
sapiens Institute one of the co-founders
as well has made a response to this
because I think that there are some
assumptions some psychological so I
should say philosophical consumptions
which are problematic which he does make
and there is a bit of reductionist
reasoning that follows as a result so no
one is perfect and although there are
issues with his let's just say
epistemological or metaphysical
worldview I don't think that means that
we can't you know generally benefit from
the man
so on this point of talking about
dopamine
um he mentions and he has a whole kind
of series on dopamine talking about if
you for example drink a cup of coffee
that your dopamine goes up a certain
lump level if you have intercourse so
you're certain dopamine goes up certain
level and then there's a subsequent
crash if you do certain activities then
your dopamine goes up and then there's a
subsequent crash and here is talking
about uh pornography and he gives some
of the risks associated with it because
obviously it raises your dopamine at a
certain level which is
um by the way something which human
humankind has never experienced before
in fact I was reading a book uh it's
called a billion and one
Wicked thoughts I don't recommend
necessarily young people read it and
there is a explicit cover of the book
which I you know if there's a way of
trying to remove that or whatever but
the book has some very interesting
information which is
for example in the very introduction the
author States something quite telling
which is that
a young person nowadays in his teenage
years may see more naked bodies
than an individual in the Victorian era
would have seen in a whole lifetime and
that is to put things in perspective we
are now in the age of internet and so
and social media exposed to so much more
than we would usually be exposed and as
a result we get bored very quickly
as a result we cannot focus on tasks
anymore as a result we've lost
discipline we've become weaker as a
result we crash a lot more we crash a
lot more
and this is something we genuinely need
to struggle with by putting in place
routines strategies that aim to minimize
or remove these kinds of things and I
think the second point that he made on
this particular video was of the utmost
pertinence which is that
sometimes when you're used to just
visually stimulating yourself and just
watching pornography watching things on
a third person level then it actually if
you want to put it colloquially bluntens
your dopamine receptors to the point
where you would for example not be able
to transfer that if you like
um in a sexual capacity with your
partner that's why a lot of for example
married people now are suffering in
sexual relationships because people are
getting their fixes men and women
by themselves they're getting their
fixes uh by satisfying themselves they
are incapable of becoming lazy actually
they have become lazy to try and engage
in the sexual process with any real
authenticity or real
um kind of
energy if you like and these are all
problems because of course and this is
another kind of research if you like
area
sexual intercourse in a marriage is one
of the things that really solidify it
for instance
um Helen Fisher for instance speaks
about love and she's a anthropologist
that does so and obviously when you have
intercourse she mentions that there are
different systems of the body one of the
systems is the dopamine system the other
one is the testosterone system the other
one is the oxytocin system
and she explains that for example when
you have intercourse with your partner
that what is released for both people is
oxytocin which of course creates a
bonding or pair bonding and these kind
of things and so if you are already
satisfying yourself outside of that or
that you're conditioning yourself before
marriage to that kind of self-pleasuring
then what you're doing is you're putting
yourself at a disadvantage when you come
into a marriage because then you're
reducing uh you know would-be interest
in your partner so these are some of the
obviously clear disadvantages from
biological from psychological uh and
from a familial perspective or from a
relationship perspective of watching
pornography but these are things World
related we have things from a Muslim
perspective which relate to our
spiritualities and which relate to the
afterlife the realm of the afterlife
and for us you know there are Halal
means there are means which are allowed
in the religion of Islam and the
religion of Islam is not a religion of
monasticism actually a religion which uh
degrades or demotes the status of
intercourse or even encourages uh
individuals to be in a celibate state in
any any part of their spiritual journey
like for example Christianity and not
just Catholicism but protestantism as
well though uh many now priests in the
Protestant Church especially in for
example the Church of England and so on
they've left the practice of being
celibate and so on but let's just say it
still maintains or it still remains in
big parts of the world we don't believe
that that is the solution because sexual
or sexuality is something like a wave
you can't just stand in front of it
because you will be engulfed by it
it's not about standing in front of
sexuality it's being able to maneuver
sexuality in a way which
allows you to to function as a
reasonable member of society and in a
way which allows you to actually get
pleasure from sex the thing is with
pornography is that it can create
boredom in the sexual experience which
of course is catastrophic because sex is
predicated on excitement curiosity and
Novelty but if you've seen it all
already then it kills the experience
now what I want to say uh in addition to
this therefore or in addition is
if one
what Islam proposes is that one gets an
obviously into a marriage if one is not
married and many of you guys are going
to be single and it's not not having sex
with their partners because there's no
partner to have sex with then it is a
good opportunity for you to know that
you can control yourself on the sexual
capacity
it is a good opportunity for you to know
that restrict this is an opportunity for
you to be restricted to restrict
yourself from seeing certain things and
doing certain things
and that will build within yourself a
kind of mental resilience okay which
will feature in your life make you a
stronger person in your life make you an
individual who is not just easily uh
hedonistic or crumbles under the
slightest pressure you know individual
that cannot control themselves and we
all have work to do in this Regard in
fact there's a Hadith or the prophet he
says that you know everyone has a a a
portion of zinner that they'll be
attached to zinnabi being
um
you know the actual translation would be
fornication or or engaging in some kind
of promiscuity however
obviously it doesn't mean that you're
gonna do that like outside of
extramarital or premarital way you can
just be watching it and this is what is
intended by the Hadith the point is here
that
it's almost inescapable that you're
going to fall into the sin if you're
living in this earth and you're not
asexual or castrated or for example have
some issue however it's about limiting
the sin to a point where it doesn't take
hold of you think of Desire or sexual
desire as a fire
you see it has to be warm enough to keep
you warm but not hot enough to burn you
and destroy you and with that I hope you
have some um uh you know incentive if
you like to put in place an action plan
if you are suffering from addiction for
example because any kind of addiction
can be broken yes any kind of addiction
can be if you're suffering from
pornography addiction that now you have
enough reason and going back to
um if I would call it the Cornerstone of
motivation if you have a why then anyhow
it's possible you're why now
can be strengthened and if you really
have a motivation to stop being addicted
to pornography then you have to put an
action plan for yourself which includes
but it's not limited to the fact that
you can't trust yourself alone in
certain areas
cut things from the root
if you are if you know there's certain
triggers that trigger you to the sexual
experience or certain psychological
reasons why you are addicted to this
thing maybe it's a form of escapism you
have to address those things because
when you relieve yourself and you get
rid of this thing from your life I
genuinely believe that you will actually
Ironically in a sense have more pleasure
you'll gain more pleasure and Islam is
not against pleasure
fact there was three men that came to
the prophet one of them says I'll never
have sex you know I'll never get married
and I've never you know engage in this
in my life he said this is whoever goes
against my I Get Married the prophet
said and whoever goes against my way is
not from me
meaning we're not once again encouraging
a celibate lifestyle we're encouraging a
disciplined one and I hope with that you
have the motivation to to go forward and
to put yourself an action plan that
removes the sin to spiritualize and
purify yourself uh from this despicable
uh action to sin and hopefully with that
uh you will benefit
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again
Santa establishing a Masjid to convey
The Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway do you know this
and I know this so that makes the Lord
even greater so give generously and
Allah azzawajal give you even more